[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas on air
ich bin selbst heeressportler als
behinderten schwimmer und wir wollen mit
diesem podcast die tollen geschichten
die menschen die persönlichkeiten hinter
den über 450 herres sportlerinnen und
sportlern davon sogar 20 mit behinderung
euch näher bringen und in der heutigen
folge haben wir tennisprofi und shooting
star derzeit in aller munde juri
rodionov bei uns herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für deine zeit und es war
einsetzen wenn du hast nämlich
sensationell gespielt die letzten wochen
hat das natürlich harte wochen mit dem
french open hat in sankt petersburg
gespielt im stadthallen turnier aber die
french open waren das absolute mega
turnier für dich vom preisgeld fangen
wir gleich mit diesem finanziellen an
hat sich das glaube ich super gelohnt
über 80.000 euro preisgeld ich glaube
viele fragen sich da immer was macht man
wenn man als junger sportler so viel
geld durch seinen sport verdient was
macht jetzt mit dem geld also erstmals
ist eine große erleichterung
so eine späte zu bekommen aber in meinem
stadion wo ich jetzt bin ich bin jetzt
140 in der welt und ich muss leider
jeden penny den ich verdiene wieder in
den sport investieren für trainer für
trainingslager für features für massagen
und einfach versucht man jetzt mal
prosten einander zu machen deswegen
80.000 klingt viel es ist auch viel aber
keine sport ist auch einer der tollsten
sportarten die man winkel
das heißt was jetzt nicht so einen
sportwagen am parkplätze stehen dann
nach dem guten turnierverlauf aber
erzählen mal selbst die war frankreich
für dich ich meine dass wahrscheinlich
so viele eindrücke nach der
erfolgreichen qualifikation die quali
runden überstanden hat dann im hauptfeld
welche eindrücke hast du alle gewonnen
und das ist in dir vorgegangen
im laufe des turniers also erstmal die
zwei wochen in paris waren
unglaublich für mich ich werde immer in
erinnerung halten dass sich das hat mich
das erste mal qualifiziert habe dass ich
meine erste runde gewonnen
auf eines anderen lernen gegen den schah
die jungen franzosen ich habe gesehen
dass ich oben mitmischen kann dass mein
niveau was sie jetzt habe gut genug ist
um in die top 100 zu kommen was auch in
den nächsten paar monaten im nächsten
ein zwei jahren ein ganz großes ziel
turnierverlauf war in dem sinne immer
wieder anstrengend und auch
herausfordern du hast auch wahnsinnig
wahnsinnigen tennis gespielt matchbälle
abgewehrt und trotzdem noch irgendwie
geschafft weiter zu kommen also ist da
auch meine mentale stärke die du
anscheinend hast auch zum vorschein
gekommen ist das etwas was wichtig ist
genau solche spiele ich würde sagen im
tennis ist sehr wichtig mental stark zu
sagen weil es ein einzelsport ist und es
ist ein kampf mann gegen mann re stärker
ist oder auch im franz.k der ths und ja
ich würde sagen dass meine mentalität
eine große stärke ist immer dass ich
mich dabei sind gegner in das match und
unbedingt wir mit jedem mittel gewinnen
möchte gab es einen einem knackpunkt wo
du sagst ab da war für mich klar da geht
was da ist was drin nach dem ersten
quali spiel nach dem zweiten grades
spiel kommt man das ein bisschen ein
floh
ja man konnte ihn ein floh aber man
realisiert dass nicht wirklich weil in
der quali zu spielen und dem hauptfeld
ist ein großer unterschied weil wir sind
mehr oder weniger zwei verschiedene
turniere man muss drei quali runden
gewinnen um ins hauptfeld zu kommen und
das ist das ist nicht leicht deswegen
schaut man einfach tag für tag werden
dass man sich verbessert dass man sein
niveau hält und einfach im match alles
gibt und als es dann geschafft hast und
im hauptfeld warst aber wahrscheinlich
schon die die die kirche auf dem
treppchen war dass sogar die erwartung
dass du da noch weiter kommst also als
ich das letzte quali match gewonnen habe
im quali finale
ist man einfach ein stern vom herzen
gefallen und ich habe einige zeit
gebraucht um zu realisieren dass ich in
meinem ersten grand slam hauptfeld
stehen
das war eigentlich schon viel erreicht
häkchen gemacht
super turnier und alles was danach kommt
ist ein bonus und ich habe mir
vorgenommen dass sie in der ersten runde
einfach mein bestes tennis zeigen
werther und da wirklich spaß haben werde
das ist glaube ich auch wichtig weil die
drucksituation hat sich sicher auch
enorm verändert dies da diese spaß haben
diese lockerheit etwas produzieren
schwer tust oder kommt das relativ
locker von handball teilen tennis ab und
so kann es schwer sagen
besonders wenn man zum beispiel mit
schmerzen mit verletzung spielt die ich
leider in paris gehabt habe dass ich
körperliche probleme hatte aber das ist
immer ein ziel wenn ich deine spiel egal
ob training oder turnier natürlich spaß
am tennis ist mein beruf und es gibt
nichts schöneres als einen beruf zu
haben die man liebt und wo es liegt eine
leidenschaft ist ein beruf jeden tag zu
machen und deswegen ist es für mich ein
hauptpunkt dass ich einfach meinen quasi
mein leben genießen wir nachmittag
genießen
du bist profi weil jetzt gesagt dass das
dann beruf des profis 2017 ist auch beim
bundesheer als herr sportler sei 2017
hast da die grundausbildung gemacht und
dann auch schon fulminant los gelegt mit
tollen erfolgen auf der challenger tour
und jetzt anscheinend auch in richtung
atp-tour
jetzt hast du vorher in kurzen punkt
erwähnt nämlich die top 100 die da so
eine grenze sind die unbedingt erreicht
werden muss im tennis das bedeutet dass
in den top 100 zu sein nicht nur vom
eigenen selbstwertgefühl aber auch von
den umständen von den rahmenbedingungen
was verändert sich alles wenn man ein
top 100 spieler ist ja das erste das
größte ist die finanzielle sicherheit
dass wenn man top 100 ist und sich
einige jahre total gut fürs leben weil
allein wenn man die vier grand slams
turnier spielte sind insgesamt schon
250.000 euro im jahr und auch einfach
dass die möglichkeit sieht oder der weg
nicht mehr so weit scheint noch weiter
zu kommen die top 50 in die top 30 war
und eines ist die
der top 100 marken sondern seine
magische zahl die für viele spieler sehr
schwer ist sie zu durchdringen
man kann sich vorstellen dass ein
spieler der 180 steht hat 300 punkte und
ein spieler der top 100 steht hat zum
beispiel 700 dass der sprung ist sehr
groß und man muss wirklich viele gute
turniere spielen um in die top 100 zu
kommen und ich stehe jetzt 140 und hat
noch immer 150 200 punkte zu machen um
in die top 100 zu kommen und kann man
auch abschätzen wie lange das jetzt
dauern wird also das so hinkommt davon
bin ich überzeugt aber kannst du sagen
ja so in den nächsten vier fünf sechs
monaten sollte es passieren wenn alles
gut geht oder ist das einfach überhaupt
nicht planbar
ja ich habe das gemacht ich war vor
zweieinhalb jahren vor zwei jahren stand
ich schon 180 und 23 19
ich habe mir vorgenommen für das jahr
2009/10 dass ich in die top 100 kommen
wo ich vorteil gescheitert bin
deswegen bin ich kein fan davon
langfristige ziele zu machen ich bin
eher jemand der step by step einfach
jeder stunde jeden tag nutzen um das
beste zu machen und dann kommt der
erfolg von von selber und wirklich
abzuschätzen wann der moment kommt dass
man den durchbruch geschafft ist meiner
meinung nach unmöglich kannst du dich
noch erinnern wann bei dies ungefähr der
punkt war wurde gesagt dass sich
radprofi also wie verläuft also dieser
gedanke in der jungen tennis-karriere
oder wieso zum tennis gekommen und dann
den gedanken zu haben
profi zu werden ich habe mich
entschieden profi zu werden also ich 14
war es war einfach der punkt da wo ich
meine neunte schuljahr beendet hatte und
die chance da war das ist quasi mit der
schule aufhören nicht nur tennis tennis
fokussiert und ich habe lange gespräche
mit meinen eltern gefühl sagen natürlich
es war nicht einfach aber sie haben mich
immer unterstützt und der mann gesagt
wenn du tennisspieler werden möchte dass
tätig und konzentriert sich 100 prozent
auf den sport und auf den beruf das habe
ich auch gemacht und da bin ich
natürlich sehr dankbar dass meine eltern
mir das vertrauen geschenkt haben meine
eigenen entscheidungen zu treffen
das muss man sich auch gedanken dazu
auch wirklich einmal visualisieren was
es bedeutet kannst du ungefähr aufzeigen
was das bedeutet dass man in dem alter
sagt ich will profi und konzentriere
mich voll darauf dass sind auch enorme
investitionen die man da tätigen muss
nicht immer hundertprozentig klar ist ob
dann auch wirklich der sprung ins
profitum gelingt oder ich bin aber auch
ein typ der nur einen plan braucht oder
brauchen muss weil wenn ich zum beispiel
im klaren plan gehabt dann könnte es
mich verlieren oder mich vom weg weisen
und ich denke auch das ist eine riesen
prämie privileg für mich mit 14 schon
gewusst zu haben was ich fürs leben
machen möchte weil es gibt nicht kenne
viele menschen die 25 26 27
die man nicht wirklich wissen was sie
für ihr leben machen wollen und ich
denke das ist einfach nur wieder eine
große sache für mich wo ich sehr dankbar
bin für mich selber dass ich gewusst
habe was ich machen möchte ist auch
etwas was du sagst dass du das aus dem
sport vielleicht gelernt hast oder mit
genommen hast dass du diese
zielgerichtet schon früher hattest oder
auch dadurch vielleicht eine
selbständigkeit die die zwangsweise
kommt die andere bietet gesagt hast
junge menschen vielleicht so noch nicht
haben
ich denke das kommt mit dem sport
einfach diese competitiveness dass man
einfach gewinnen möchte dass man einfach
gewohnte ist hart zu arbeiten weil das
in jedem sport touristen das wenn man
ohne fleiß kein preis
wenn du wenn du nicht genug investiert
in den sport haben wir jetzt einfach
nicht funktionieren und ich denke da
sage ich auch auf mein privates leben
ein bisschen provozieren lassen was bin
ich nicht schlecht ist
du warst 2017 eben in der
grundausbildung auch kurz vor dem sprung
zum profi tun was hast du da gelernt
wenn man da zusammen ist mit anderen
angehenden herres sportlern gibt es da
so zwei drei aspekte oder dich erinnerst
und sagst ja das hab ich eine
grundausbildung gelernt was habe ich für
meine karriere mitnehmen können ich muss
sagen die grundausbildung war für mich
eigentlich eine tolle zeit aber ich habe
es mir ein bisschen schlimmer
vorgestellt aber die fünf wochen die
waren wirklich eine gute erfahrung für
mich als mensch und als sportler weil
war einfach eine andere seite sieht vom
leben die man einfach so nicht kennt man
ich kenne nicht dass sportler sich jeden
tag um 6
[Musik]
danach eine stunde meine schuhe putzen
muss und das hat mir einige sachen
mitgenommen erstens dass ich meine
kleider besser falten kann also dass da
wird sich glaube ich auch meine mutter
gefreut haben und zweitens auch was für
eine möglichkeit ich habe und dass ich
als sportler quasi das mache was ich
liebe und es selber nicht als arbeit
sehen und es gibt leute die wirklich von
tal bis nachts arbeiten und ab und zu
auch wirklich an keine lust haben auf
ihren beruf und plus dazu dass ich gut
verdienen kann und dass ich einfach
wirklich gelernt hab gehört ist das ist
dein leben seine sportler und wie viele
viele leute müssen hart dafür arbeiten
um ihr gehalt zu kommen und für mich ist
das nicht tat weil ich jetzt einfach
nicht als job sondern einfach als
aufnehmen und das zeigt sich dann auch
in erfolgen das jetzt kurz seine mutter
angesprochen deine eltern da kommen ja
aus weißrussland du bist in deutschland
geboren und dann aber früh nach nach
österreich gezogen und hier aufgewachsen
ist das seit 2005 zehn österreichische
staatsbürger war für dich jemals thema
für ein anderes land zu spielen zu
starten und ein anderes land internet
vertreten oder wolltest du immer schon
unbedingt österreich vertreten ich habe
das schon oft gesagt aber ich habe mich
immer als österreicher gefühlt weil ich
bin hier aufgewachsen ich bin hier zur
schule gegangen ich habe österreich
freunde gehabt ich bin umgezogen aus
deutschland was ich selber also ich habe
keine erinnerungen aus deutschland und
ja ich interessiere mich einfach als
österreichische mentalität und ich bin
einfach stolz österreichischer
staatsbürger so sagen und das sind wir
natürlich auch stolz dass du österreich
vertritt aber auch natürlich das
bundesheer jetzt eine letzten monate
nicht nur für dich sehr aufregend weil
sie erfolgreich waren aber auch für die
gesamte welt und vor allem auch typisch
österreichischer sportwelt das sehr
ereignisreich wie es dir zu keiner zeit
gegangen
du hast wahrscheinlich gemerkt davor
dass deine form kommt dass du gut in
form bist und dann kommt mal der
einschnitt und das ist einmal nix los
und ungewissheit wie es der da in dieser
situation gegangen
vom lockdown hatte ich in dieser form
nicht aus den vier turnieren habe ich 2
gewonnen und natürlich war
das für mich ein großer schlag aber ich
denke ich den locker gut genutzt da ich
habe sehr viel an mir gearbeitet haben
am körper und auch mich mental
vorbereitet für für die wiedereröffnung
und natürlich wie viele monate waren es
45 das waren schon sehr lange die man
allein verbracht hat aber ich habe das
beste draus gemacht und das hat sich
ausgezahlt im blick hast du auf die
vielen dinge die dann so neben dem sport
passiert sind wo dann die herzsportler
auch ausgeholfen haben gesellschaftlich
etwas zurückgegeben haben wie siehst du
das wenn da so spitzensportler leute die
medaillen gewinnen weil
weltmeisterschaften
europameisterschaften plötzlich in
lebensmittel lagern mithelfen welchen
blick hast du auf so was man darf nicht
vergessen dass alle athletinnen und
athleten immer noch menschen sind egal
ob man olympia-gold gewonnen hat und ob
man nummer eins in der welt die sind
irgendwann sport man sonst noch ein
mensch und ich finde das ist ein gutes
zeichen dass man den leuten auch das
zeigt dass man noch immer ein wertvoller
baustein für die gesellschaft ist und
einfach auch mithelfen kann und damit
auch wirklich signifikant beitragen kann
jetzt weiß man dass tennis nicht nur
hatte es beim spielen sondern auch hat
beim training tennisspieler und
natürlich auch seine spielerinnen sind
teilweise die komplettesten
sportlerinnen und sportler die man auch
finden kann müssen sowohl ausdauernd
sein wenn sich so ein spiel über fünf
sätze zieht wie wir über dir aber auch
schnell spritzig wie kann man sich
ungefähr einen trainingsalltag
vorstellen und wie schaffst du das als
sportler diesen trainings alltag zu
bewältigen es viel abwechslung für ihn
fahre also ich habe man hat immer
zeit schnitt derzeit abschnitte in dem
man verschiedene blogs macht entweder
schnelligkeit oder explosivkraft und
findet immer zeit an den zu arbeiten und
die zu verbessern aber keine sport ist
einer der kompliziertesten sportarten
weil man dann nicht nur eine gewisse
bewegung machen muss sondern man braucht
einfach ist das touristen beim
einschwimmen dass man nur einige muskeln
wirklich braucht weil man so weit ich
weiß vier verschiedene stile hat im
schwimmen also ich würde ich stimme dir
und im tennis braucht einfach alles
finden auf schlag braucht man viele
rückenmuskulatur und schultermuskulatur
für die frau andere kennt viele montag
man muss sich sehr gut bewegen können
und da in sehr vielen bereichen arbeiten
gespeichert von metall
natürlich ist es auch eine sehr
schwierige sportart weil man immer mann
gegen mann ist und am schluss können die
kleinsten kinder entscheiden wer gewinnt
oder verliert wie sie deinen
trainingsumfeld ganz konkret aus du
trainierst du im team team habe sich das
genauer vorstellen wie läuft das ab
also meistens klinge ich in der früh
fitness damit mama kritik an trainer
florian haupt und danach fahre ich das
training mit dem wolfgang thieme und
meistens drei bis vier stunden und zwei
oder dreimal die woche habe ich ein
fischer termin in der massage theologen
ist auch in meinem team und ich bin
jetzt sehr zufrieden mit meinem team ist
ein sehr kompaktes team auch sehr
familiär so zum beispiel mein bruder ist
mein manager und sind einfach sehr viele
charaktere die den ich vertrau und die
ich auch sehr mag
und wenn man so tagtäglich auch mit
einem der besten spieler der welt
trainiert gibt es etwas wo du sagst das
kann ich mir ab schauen das kann ich
lernen von dominic thiem wenn er wenn er
so gemeinsam platz schließt ja natürlich
jeden tag also
allein vom zugucken wie er trainiert und
wie er sich auf das eher fürs tennis
macht sein kann man schon sehr viel
lernen und ich bin sehr dankbar für die
möglichkeit dass ich mit ihm trainieren
kann und dass ich einige dinge von ihm
abschauen kann jetzt ist doch so dass
nicht nur die derzeit supergut bisschen
das bleibt hoffentlich so sondern das
allgemeine guter junge generation in
seiner generation und 23 jahre älter als
du gibt also fast schon ein tennis boom
in österreich was glaubst das sind da
die gründe ist das rein
die die jüngsten erfolge von von dominik
oder gibt es andere gründe dafür dass
ihr da gerade am aufkommen seitz und
eines es trotzdem noch ein einzelsport
auch wenn der dortigen letzten paar
wochen monate extrem gut und sehr gute
resultate erzielt hat müssen keine
spieler trotzdem für sich selber spielen
also allein vom zugucken werde ich auf
einmal nicht wissen wie man eine bessere
form spielt also man muss das selber
erlernen und trainieren
und natürlich kann es helfen auch weiter
nicht dass man einfach professioneller
wird dass man sieht was man machen muss
man profi zu werden aber ich denke dass
einfach in den letzten paar monaten
viele spieler sehr hart besonders im
lockt also in der team- akademie haben
wir sehr hart trainiert alle zusammen
und ich denke das ist auch ein grund
warum jetzt die guten resultate kommen
das heißt er kann uns auch gute früchte
aus der lok dann zeit im tennissport
vorbereiten
jetzt hätte ich noch eine frage die mich
persönlich sehr interessiert weil der
tennissport natürlich eine super
professionell organisierte
internationale struktur hat und das ein
bisschen anders ist als in vielen
anderen weil im sommer sportarten und
für viele sportlerinnen und sportler ist
ja olympia so das allergrößte was man so
machen kann im tennis ist es ein
bisschen nicht so ganz und ich weiß dass
du fan der japanischen kultur bist jetzt
das olympia in japan sind das dinge wenn
man sich auch gedanken macht mal das
wäre toll oder es olympia ist eine
spieler wirklich er so läuft so nebenbei
also für mich sind die olympischen
spiele will ich ein großes ziel was ich
auf jeden fall spielen möchte wenn ich
die möglichkeit bekomme natürlich im
sport ist vielleicht einen kleineren
stellenwert weil es erstens mitten in
der saison ist mitten in der ganzen
saison und es einfach vom stellenwert
nicht so weit oben ist aber für mich
selber als österreichischer staatsbürger
ist es für mich sehr wichtig mein land
zu repräsentieren egal ob beim bsk hat
bei den olympischen spielen oder einfach
als soldat vom herrn sportzentrum und
kurz auf japan noch was fasziniert sich
so an der iranischen kultur wenn man so
mitbekommt dass du den fans war einmal
in japan durch nicht wirklich ins land
verliebt haben muss ist eigentlich
spielt auch mit unix japanischen
tennisschlägern und ich bin einfach
entfernen von von den leuten und von
einer ganzen kultur also ganz tokio
findet man keinen einzigen plastik sagt
bewegen wir auf der straße jeder ist
extrem hilfreich und es ist wirklich
man kann sagen eine ganz andere welt und
ich bin ein großer fan musik die ich
habe auch noch herausgefunden dass du
einige sachen schon erlebt hast auch
kuriose dinge zum beispiel musstest du
einmal eine unterhose wechseln beim
wimbledon championships 2017 warum genau
was ist da passiert
die einwendungen gibt es ja eine sehr
strikte kleidungsvorschriften und die
besagt dass ich glaube 90 prozent oder
95 prozent der kleidung weit sein muss
und bei mir war leider die unterhose
blau
das hat man durch gesehen und dann beim
beim kontors also am anfang musste ich
die der schiedsrichter mit den spielern
unterhält hat das die schiedsrichterin
und bemerkt oder schiedsrichter ich weiß
nicht ob das manche oder weiblich war
und hat mich aufgefordert meine
unterhose zum wechseln also musste ich
schnell in die umkleide und unterhose
wechseln
es war sehr kurios ich glaube es hat
mich sogar geholfen weil ich das war
achtelfinale
und ich war ein verein dann wirklich
sehr nervös und die ganze sache ein
bisschen
bisschen relaxt weil mit dem hat habe
ich einfach nicht gereicht
und genau das wollte ich auch passieren
jetzt nachdem fragen jetzt passiert
sowas ja ich meine das ist jetzt kurios
und witzig zum zuhören aber als sportler
wenn man sich vorbereitet hatte man da
hingeht wenn man ein ziel hat
und da ist plötzlich nach ich kann jetzt
nicht anfangen sondern bitter nach
unterhausen wechseln
du hast jetzt gemeindeseite geholfen
dass du ein bisschen sich entspannen
kommt es aber prinzipiell ist das nicht
etwas was dann einen die aus dem konzept
zu bringen kann oder hast du da methoden
wie du damit umgeht damit das nicht
negativ sich auswirkt ich glaube jeder
mensch ist anders also ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass wenn es einem
anderen passieren würde dass er erkennt
bei mal einspringen könnte aber in dem
fall hat es mir geholfen weil ich so
nervös war
wenn jetzt in meinem nächsten match
passiert muss ich nicht dort mehr das
hilft oder oder nicht so schwer zu sagen
aber ich versuche ich mich immer auf
mich selbst zu konzentrieren also das
was ich selber beeinflussen kann
da schaue ich das beste daraus zu machen
und wo ich nicht beeinflussen kann wie
das wetter den wind oder beeinflussen
können aber da ich schaue auf mich und
das was ich kontrollieren kann das
versuche ich ja so gut wie möglich zu
machen
hier muss jetzt sagen dass 2017 das dann
auch sehr jung also das kann schon
einmal den besten passieren gibt es auch
etwas sagst du hast bestimmte rituale
die du immer gleich machst ich steig zum
beispiel immer von der linken seite auf
der startseite beim schwimmwettkampf
weil ich mich dadurch besser mit der
rechten hand stabilisieren können gibt
es jetzt das foto einfach deine rituale
hast du deinen routine hineinzubringen
ich muss sagen ich hab kein einziges
ritual also ich bin da ich brauche das
einfach nicht
ich hab's probiert aber oftmals
behindert mich dass ein wenig und lässt
mich nicht wirklich konzentrieren auf
das was ich eigentlich machen muss weil
dann denke ich mir okay ich bin ich
bereit zum abschlagen aber ich habe noch
meine ritual vergessen und ja ich habe
dann einfach entschieden das nicht zu
machen
offensichtlich funktioniert das auch
ohne sehr gut ganz kurz zum abschluss
noch was ist ein großes ziel wo sagst du
da geht die reise hin dass es möglich
das möchte ich aus mir herausholen
kannst du das irgendwie in watte
beschreiben wie gesagt das sind vom
shoppen habe ich für furore gesorgt und
ich habe quasi die luft oben
geschnuppert wie die luft sein kann wie
schön es sein kann dort zu stehen im
hauptfeld von einem kanzler und steht
für mich fest dass dort mein ziel ist
also das ist mein ziel dort einfach jede
woche zu stehen und vor zuschauern
spielen zu können und ich wäre der fall
ist dann geben um dem ziel näher zu
kommen
ich könnte ein jahr dauern es kann in
zwei drei jahren und dauern aber ich
werde immer daran hart arbeiten das ist
mal eine ansage wir wünschen dir auf
jeden fall viel erfolg wir freuen uns
sehr über deine erfolge wir freuen uns
dass du damit auch dass herr
sportzentrum das österreichische
bundesheer erfolgreich repräsentiert
alles gute bleibt gesund und wir hoffen
dass noch viele erfolge folgen
das war es beim sport rapport dem sport
podcast des österreichischen bundesheers
danke dass sie dabei war dass wir euch
spannende menschen die geschichten
hinter den sportlerinnen und sportlern
aber näher bringen konnten und ich hoffe
es auch beim nächsten mal wieder dabei
bis dann
[Applaus]
[Musik]